this is Emma Watson's greatest
qualification to have an opinion not
saying she can't have an opinion but
she's sitting before the UN who kind of
screw up international law a whole lot
her greatest qualification is she was a
cute if awkward unibrow kid who was a
good enough actor for them to hand her
millions of dollars to take part in a
franchise before she even had her first
female cycle
gosh mo its Emma Watson or Emma Watson
so she went before the UN here and
talked about feminism god bless her
little neck all right let's start
rolling this clip here and we'll just
roll through and pause it thank you all
for being here for this important moment
these men from all over the world have
decided to make gender equality a
priority in their lives and in their
universities thank you for making this
commitment I can tell you what those men
look like I graduated from university
for wait this is too early I had always
dreamed of going and I know later it
gets into it okay so alright alright I
just want to make sure we're not wasting
people's time but gets really bad and I
want to get to that quickly before I
have an aneurysm I don't want to know no
Anita Brown became my home my community
and I took the ideas and the experiences
I had there into all of my social
interactions into my workplace into my
politics into all aspects of my life I'm
sure you did yeah I know that my
university experience shaped Who I am
yep and that's a broad course it does
for many people she's right but what if
our experience of university shows us
that women don't belong in leadership
what if it shows us that yes when they
can study but they shouldn't need a
seminar that's not shown anywhere any
what if are still in many places around
the world many poison it tells us that
women don't belong there at all are you
talking about like Saudi Arabia as is
the case in far too many universities we
are given the message that sexual
violence isn't actually a form of
violence pause this is before the UN
name one name one University that is I
can name you if the universities off of
the top of my head where gender studies
are taught rape culture is taught point
me to one University where the
curriculum is sexual assault is not
really violence 101 name one they track
this out and by the way they trot this
out to demand international sanctions to
the man international globalist rule of
law from the UN to take your rights away
we'll get into that later because the UN
called for the
it states to to give reparations to
black Americans no word yet on African
nations who sold them into slavery name
one University where rape is taught as
we swept in the wrong name one
university that teaches women you're not
allowed to be in a position of
leadership name one university that is
opposed to banning safe spaces trigger
warnings and checking your privilege
name one University that is this bastion
of misogyny and rape culture and
inequality that Emily what's her name
Emma Emma Emma Watson is talking about I
can't remember her name she's so generic
her opinions are so pedestrian
regurgitated and she's right you think
she's right the university does shape
your worldview it absolutely does and
she went in there with none she was a
girl
let's I'll get into this app because she
gets let's go wrong just go but we know
that if you change students experiences
so they have different expectations of
the world around them expectations of
equality Society will change as we leave
home for the first time to study at the
places that we have worked so hard to
get
we must not see or experience double
standards we need to see equal respect
leadership and pay alright that's enough
that's enough I can't it yet so this is
a stupid person by the way fairness she
spent ten years in dress up and play
with wine so it's got a qualify for
something yes you're absolutely right
here's the first off pay this is a dumb
person I don't know why Emma Watson was
like this meme online that people find
her attractive or there's something
about it that's compelling I can't think
of somebody more ill-informed
boring and bad at their job she's right
the university does shape their
worldview and these kids are going in
it's an indoctrination factory where
they're being taught false statistics
like you need to go before the UN to
demand more pay she couldn't be more
wrong and like you said this is Emma
Watson's greatest qualification to have
an opinion not saying she can't have an
opinion but she's sitting before the UN
who kind of screw up international law a
whole lot her greatest qualification is
she was a cute if awkward unibrow kid
who was a good enough actor for them to
hand her millions of dollars to take
part in a franchise
for she even had her first female cycle
so this woman was surrounded by piles of
cash and here's the thing she's talking
about this abyssal shape this will shape
our worldview and people will have
different expectations that's true
College does shape your worldview and
people have different expectations
that's why you have an entire generation
of social justice warriors who get their
teeth kicked in by the real world
because they get into the real world and
they realize that it's not safe spaces
and trigger warnings that's the same
thing with her here's the thing that
people can understand you know why this
story doesn't end well for most child
actors all of Hollywood is a safe space
the only place outside of University
where you have safe spaces and trigger
warnings and precious is Hollywood
why because since emma watson has been a
little girl she has had her ass kissed
by agents managers publicists producers
directors who have a vested interest to
make sure that she does not face any
real adversity of any kind because they
need to protect their product and their
brand and so she's gonna go on to the
world with unrealistic expectations just
like every child actor usually it
results in coke off some broads hip
bones in this case it results in her
lecturing the UN and the rest of the
world on how we need to pay women more
and start treating rape seriously all of
Hollywood is a safe space everything she
said there is right except for the facts
it's taken from the full-length podcast
every week you can click that box down
below to watch the full free video cast
or subscribe on iTunes to watch them to
go click my face to go to ladder with
better calm where we write plenty of
articles columns and upset those who are
easily triggered or click below me
there's some other video down there I
don't know what it is yet not gay Jarrod
is going to toss it's probably going to
be something ambiguous but uncomfortable